Brittney's with us in Florida hi
Brittany how are you better than I
deserve how are you
better than I deserve what's up okay I
have a question about income this Friday
they're going to be garnishing my wages
due to unpaid student loan debt and I am
a hundred and fifty seven thousand
dollars in debt and at my job part-time
I only take home four hundred and fifty
dollars what can I do to increase my
income and how do I go about paying off
the medical bills in student loan debt
how old are you 25 what's your degree in
I work retail right now but my admission
Cosmetology been one hundred fifty seven
thousand dollars for cosmetology no the
hundred and fifty is from medical bills
I only owe 67 hundred in student loan
but the student loans are garnishing you
or the medicals garnishing you the
student loans okay
and so why are you only working
part-time if you have a cosmetology
degree why don't you cut in here um for
that it took some time to build up my
parents got really sick so for the past
couple of years I've been helping them
in the business and it's only just now
that I start working on my own and with
the hours I work at work I'm not able to
help them anymore so what's the medical
expenses are theirs or yours they're
mine okay so yeah obviously we've gone
through some illness as well right yes I
have are you doing better now um God
willing yes I will be I'm handling this
situation that I have I don't exactly
know how much in medical I just know
it's from a hundred thousand to a
hundred and fifty thousand Atmos okay so
did you have a prolonged hospital stay
yes they did so a large portion of that
has to do to one hospital yes
okay all right well the first thing
we've got there's two sides to any
equation here and one you know one side
and you address both of them in your
question is income side and the outgo
side so obviously we've got to get you
making more than 450 bucks a month
you're starving to death right yes thank
you okay so is there not a cosmetology
position you can get in full-time that
pays like adult wages I could it just
takes a few months because you need to
have a certain amount of clients to come
with you and that's the part that
deterred me the first time was I didn't
have that time taking care of my parents
okay but I'm asking now are we gonna do
to get you into a career out of 4.4 $50
a month yes I've been applying to some
local boutiques here but where I live
it's a small town so there's not many
opportunities so the school that I went
to originally I had to drive two hours
to get to and right now my car can't go
over 40 miles an hour without shutting
down so that kind of limits me on where
I can apply to do you need to move yes I
do because we've got to do something
kiddo to get your income up you can't
just sit there in the soup and get
anything but boiled okay
so we've got to make some kind of moves
I don't know what they are you got a lot
of things pulling at you I can hear it a
messed-up car mom and dad are sick
you've been sick you got this big pile
of debt but we've got to do something to
get your income up all right so um
that's a big deal here now once we've
done that let's just establish that
you're gonna go figure that part out
okay and I'm gonna send you come via Ken
Coleman's book proximity principle to
help you once we've done that let's say
you start making 40 50 60 thousand
dollars a year over the next couple
years you can go sit down with that
hospital in person and hospitals are a
business they are an industry however I
generally find compact
people working even in the
administrative office and I'll bet
you've got an $80,000 loan sitting there
with our medical debts in there with
them but you can probably settle with
them if you walked in with 10 or $15,000
because they're probably have mercy on
your Plus they can look at your
situation no they're not gonna get paid
anytime soon so they'll settle with you
but you're going to get some income
together to do that with